this is I'm adil down I'm talking I'm
going to be talking today about recent
advances in melanoma therapy and my I'm
a clinical professor of medicine and
co-director of the melanoma program at
University of California San Francisco
and my topic today is on is to discuss
some of the recent advances in melanoma
there's been an incredible amount of
advances lately in melanoma and some of
these advances are have been in the news
media and here's just a small collection
of headlines melanoma and immunotherapy
and have been all over the press and
these are shots from Lhasa from the Los
Angeles Times and from the New York
Times and from nature talking about some
of these new drugs and a breakthrough
breakthroughs in melanoma that we've
seen with these new drugs if you look at
skin cancer overall in the United States
there's a lot of cases of skin cancer
and if you especially look at the
incidence of skin cancer there's over
three million cases of skin cancer in
the United States and those include
basal cells queima cells melanomas and a
very kind of cancer known as merkel cell
the most common kind of skin cancer is
actually basal cell cancer in this over
2.8 million basal cells in the United
States in a year so that's actually more
common than any other type of skin
cancer squamous cell cancers are also
pretty common there's this point seven
million or 700,000 squamous cell cancer
cases in the United States or in a year
and then if you look at melanomas it's
actually a relatively unusual type of
skin gets up as 60,000 cases in a year
if you look at the deaths though from
melanoma they are they in excess of any
other type of skin cancer there's 8,000
patients dying of melanoma while only a
you thousand from squamous cell cancer
almost nobody dies from basal cell
cancer the six hundred deaths from from
Merkel cell cancer which is a very rare
kind of cancer that we think has a viral
causation it's interesting for me to
look at this map of the United States in
and look at cancer mortality rates
focusing on just white males from 1972
1994 and you look at just white males
it's interesting that the highest areas
of cancer mortality from melanoma are in
the southern part of the country and if
you look at if you look at this southern
part of the United States that's where
most of the cancer most of the melanoma
deaths occur you'll notice that it in
places like Wisconsin and Minnesota
there's actually a very small number
white men dying from melanoma what if
you look at Georgia and Mississippi
California Texas Florida and the
Carolinas that's where most of the
cancer that sort of constitutive so kind
of gives you a flavor for what's going
on and I think it's this is a complex
question and you know people talk about
ultraviolet radiation but also it's
important to remember that even though
people were going out to the beach you
know in the 30s and 20s people were a
lot more covered I love this picture
which is taken at the beach in New
Jersey in the 1930s see that guy there
with the sleeping with this with his tie
on shoes on and that's the way people
were in the region and if you look at
people at the beach today of course
there's a lot more that there's a lot
less clothing to protect you from the
Sun so it's so I think it's a
complicated question but certainly we
are getting exposed to a lot more
ultraviolet radiation today than we used
to in the past so one of the crucial
breakthroughs
in melanoma research really came in the
early 2000s then my colleagues here
Horace Bastian and others and many other
investigators around the world including
Helen babies and Britain showed that if
you look at cancer and if you look at
melanoma specifically where the melanoma
comes from seems to determine the
likelihood of specific mutations so for
example if you look at I melanoma so
uveal melanoma almost none of them have
a mutation in B lab and about eighty to
ninety percent have mutations in these g
proteins called g11 and GNA q if you
look at Madeleine was in the trunk or in
or in lot of lower extremities a lot of
those melanomas have mutations in V
Ralph about sixty percent of them almost
have mutations in the birria of gene and
if you look at now I was occurring in
the mucosa very few of them have BRF
mutations and similarly with nylon ones
from the nails or or from the feed your
hand or known as a cola dizziness
melanomas very few of them have p
reputation so just giving you an ID to
just give me your flavor for the
mutation status vary depending on where
the mal de la crisis if you look at
signal transduction map of the cell
you'll notice that if you plot a lot of
frequent mutations in melanoma a lot of
them map to what's known as the map
kinase pathway so a lot of mutations are
in either b-raf which is right here or
neck which is right here or n rass which
is right here or in 10 SB 16 which is
right here and right here please 21 and
p16 and some of the other mutations are
in the spear 3 kinase pathway right here
and so if you just map them out you
realize that a lot of them are
downstream of growth factor signaling
especially the map kinase pathway
that's given rise to this idea that if
you were to block this map kinase
pathway you get some mileage from
melanoma treatment so just to move gears
a little bit to more clinical outcome
data in melanoma if you look at melanoma
survival by strange you'll notice that
of course Stage four melanomas
associated very poor survival and if you
look at if you look at stage 4 melanoma
and if you look at the fifty percent
survival that's that's rude right over
here it's it's that's generally a year
or less but even if you look at the
stage one melanoma so you're talking
about very thin melanomas you'll notice
that if you look at the five-year
survival which is right here you realize
that it's approximately ninety percent
and if you look at the 10-year survival
it's maybe about eighty eighty-five
percent and if you look at the 15 year
survival it's even less than that so
just giving you an idea that none on
survival even very thin legions does not
plateau so over time you'll have you'll
have some patients who died off na gawa
even with very thin melanomas even
beyond the first five years which is
different from other types of cancers
where you know if you made it to five
years you're probably good to go so one
of the early advances in ambala was what
the technique of settle lymph node
biopsy and here's slides that were
provided to me by dr. Douglas Rankin
who's at moffitt cancer center and he he
and many others pioneered this technique
where you will inject dye a blue dye
around the site of a primary melanoma
and then track it to the regional lymph
node take the limit on out look at it
microscopically and attacked left on her
head melanoma it then that patient was
considered to be stage 3 versus stage 1
if that look mode was negative and so
the settlement known technique really
revolutionized the staging of melanoma
so now we can tell with a lot of
you know with a lot of accuracy but that
somebody has a stage 1 stage 2 or stage
3 melanoma and that makes a big
difference to prognosis and helps us to
plan who needs to help further treatment
and here's a photo micrograph showing
that same sentiment code from the
patient shown earlier and just showing
that if you look at this patient you can
see that this patient has a focus of
melanoma cells that you can see on the
edge in a section on the left hand side
and then when that section is standing
by s100 you can see that the that stains
positive is 100 indicating that this is
a little focus of melanoma cells in that
lymph node so showing that this patient
had stage 3 melanoma so what can we do
for melanoma that's spread to the lymph
node and how can we prevent that now no
one from coming back because we know
that a certain proportion of those
patients will go on to develop systemic
melanoma and I right so some of the the
treatments that have been studied are
interferon-alpha either native or
pegylated which is a near fall
interferon-alpha vaccines gm-csf or
granulocyte-macrophage
colony-stimulating factor and also this
drug called aluminum and also start
briefly about all these different
options so the first treatment and the
treatment that has a lot of clinical
trials and has been studied excessively
melanomas this drug interferon
interferon was discovered in the late
1950s by investigators in Japan who
found that in fear on prevented or
protected from influenza or from viral
illnesses and subsequently in fear on
was treated in cancer was true in a lot
of different indications including
hepatitis C and in melanoma particularly
it's being extensively tested from the
late from the early 1990s actually and
the first most important trial that was
done was the econ 1684 by John Kirkwood
and multiple other classes you can see
this meta-analysis so the one thing that
seems to stand out for it if you're on
that
very few people dispute is that
interferon definitely reduces the
recurrence rate of mono- just this
meta-analysis just points to that if you
look at the hazard ratios for in fear on
you can see that almost every interferon
trial favors the addition of interferon
in terms of reducing response rate that
you can see that that all of these
trials are on the left side of the one
hazard ratio of showing favor if you're
on only one trial did not favor and if
you're on in terms of the currents free
survival so that part is is absolutely
you know without question that
interferon reduces recurrence but the
more difficult question is does it
improve survival and this just shows
that again if you look at it if you're
on either high dose intermediate those
or even lodos interferon you you'll see
a reduction in recurrence the problem is
where you try to see and try to
establish even if you're on improve
survival there the picture isn't very
clear here you can see that some trials
do favor in fear on in terms of overall
survival you can see that e [ __ ] 69 for
favorite interferon for survival but a
lot of the trials cluster near the one
line basically showing no benefit or a
slight benefit at best and if you put
this together mathematically you can see
that the hazard ratio is much less
impressive for survival than it was for
recurrence you can see that for
recurrence the p-value is highly
significant one for survival the p-value
is not very significant and depending on
what trials you include or exclude you
can see a benefit either a small benefit
or sometimes even no real benefit
so our other treatments that are being
tried in a preventative setting include
gm-csf vaccines and if a little map and
I think today there isn't a lot of data
that either one of them will prevent
relapse or help overall survival I think
that is in fact some data that vaccine
that means some vaccines my even worse
and survival and again with the blue map
trials haven't been reported but but but
there isn't a clear signal that it alone
man helps in terms of recurrence so
right now most people do not recommend
using it Luna for survival now 44 in
terms of adjuvant treatment of melanoma
now what about stage for melanoma
metastatic melanoma where that's the
more heavy duty mellon over the tumor
may have spread to your lung or liver or
live tones or some other place beyond
the regional draining lymph nodes so
until 2010 almost every randomized trial
invalid on what was negative and this
just shows some of the trials in our
dacarbazine versus temozolomide that
trial was negative the that's this trial
here your PC 1803 to carbon tax Hall vs
carbo tax all plus the ravanar also
negative prison which was the same trial
but in the second line setting-
dacarbazine versus channel Lumira which
is a CTA for anybody again that trial
was negative gp100 vs if the look-around
was positive and so that was a dud sound
player but the car busy in versus
dacarbazine plus all glimmer sin was
negative and the beam trial also was
negative so so so really except for this
mdx 010 trial every channel private
train 10 was negative and people
despaired of if any treatment Adnan or
whatever shows the Royal debit so
imagine everybody surprised when this
when Keith clarity and his colleagues
reported on a beer at Minton's nah no
one responding extremely well to
on you be wroth inhibitor and this was
reported you know couple of papers in
new england journal of medicine and in
nature published in august two thousand
ten showing drastic african efes
efficacy and this is just to give you a
flavor of that response rate this is a
patient who was over at a PET scan at
baseline and by day 15 and you can see
that even by david keene a lot of his
tumor had so like you could see that his
lymph node disease here is is remarkably
improved his axillary lymph node disease
here is almost gone you could see that
mr. patient who had tumors in his liver
and lungs you could see that his liver
now looks almost without any disease
here if you look down at his lung
nodules they're gone by eight weeks
liver lesions and are extremely reviews
like look at this station now it's not
less than half the size and this is all
within eight weeks in and the remarkable
response rate that was reported in this
study was a response overall objective
response rate of eighty-one percent so
unprecedented from Eleanor one and this
just shows the response rate by one pulp
lot so you can see that all of these
patients here these patients here all of
these patients here had tumor shrinkage
so you could see really except for this
one patient here who had who had tumor
progression and this patient here who
had a little bit of cumin progression
everybody else had shrinkage of disease
so remarkable for a melanoma trial I
think previously if you looked at
melanoma trials you'd see maybe some
patients here respond but everybody else
would have progression of disease so
just just remarkable results so once
this be rapid manner I showed such great
responses in phase one it was tested in
a phase 3 trial where patients were
randomized to very rapid
which is a bit severe alkenyl video
versus dacarbazine and 675 patients were
randomized in this study and what they
showed was again remarkable responses
and this is just the most updated data
on that trial you could see that the
response rate dacarbazine was only eight
point six percent while you can see that
the response rates to remember alpha
four fifty-seven percent and so just a
major difference in an objective
response rate and if you looked at
progression-free survival there's a
major difference also dacarbazine only
one point six months then your opponent
six point nine months so almost a
five-month difference in
progression-free survival now objective
response was high progression-free
survival was was extremely good but
overall survival not as impressive there
was a four-month difference in overall
survival nine point seven months for the
curves into thirteen point six months
from every ravelin if you look at who
responded best you can see that almost
everybody responded best responded
better with fairly rapid versus
dacarbazine only patients who had showed
any real ambiguous results were the
patients with stage 3c melanoma and some
of the patients with stage one email
Norma everybody else men women older
people younger people low performance
status high performance at us everybody
did better than you're out there so
people talk well if you could get a lot
of mileage with BF inhibitors which
which work here if you could get even
more mileage with BF + negativity which
you know would block dispatch the two
different levels so it's kind of like
blocking a river to die so a river might
overflow one damn but two dams that
that's gonna take more time how about
that there's some preclinical support
for this idea and in animals you could
see that if you give a BF + MEK
inhibitor you can get much more violence
that's that line over here the last line
in red showing that tumors couldn't grow
untreated tumors grow rapidly in
xenograft model if you give just
immaculate that's the orange line here
trendnet tumors still grow very rapidly
if you do the problem which is the green
line they grow rapidly if you but if you
do both together you can pretty much
suppress tumor growth and Lance that red
line here up to off all the way up to 90
days so be another and some of my other
colleagues including Keith glad he
explored this in a trial and we reported
this last year and what we showed is
that again a tremendous different so you
could see that if you do just the BF in
a bitter that's this line here that
shows a I should take that back if you
do just a beta of innovator that's this
line in yellow and that's the
monotherapy arm and if you do the
combination of beer f+ neck of the
high-dose that's this green line here so
you could see that the difference in
median progression-free survival changes
from five point eight months or
monotherapy definite versus nine point
four months to the combination and deb
raffinate is a beer up in a bitter
that's made by glaxosmithkline it's now
approved for treatments in melanoma and
it's a different drug from the very
rapid m and in this trial in this
combined with shredded it which is a mek
inhibitors also showing a major
difference progression-free survival
with the combination in this randomized
phase two trial the waterfall plot very
impressive again showing most patients
benefiting greatly only a smattering of
patients showing any type of progression
so with that let me turn your attention
to immunotherapy and immunotherapy and
does have a long history in no no we
talked about in you interferon which is
a type of immunotherapy that works on in
a and adapt
community and so one of the major
advances on our in our field was if a
little bit bad which we talked about a
few slides ago and it's it's an anti
ctla-4 antibody and so I this next set
of sites just reviews the mechanism
action of a below map and another
immunotherapy antibody called PD 11 and
we'll just we'll just walk through the
mechanism of action of these antibodies
so if you look at a tumor cell when
actual cell has emitted what we call
immunogenic cell death what will happen
is that our little fragments of tumor
cell will be ingested by an antigen
presenting cell or dendritic cell and
then this general Excel presents these
same antigens in the context of the
major histocompatibility protein on on
its surface MHC 2 which docks to what's
known as a t-cell receptor TCR and then
that along with what we call signal to
which has the rich uses a cold
stimulatory molecule to bind to cd28 to
on the t cell and that connection but
the signal one at signal to is what
stimulates the t-cells and then once
these t-cells are stimulated then the T
cells will then go and kill tumor cells
again recognizing the tumor cells with
the T cell receptor right here so that's
how the immune system works now there's
many levels at which the immune system
it can be turn now one level that can be
done down is through what's known as a
PD ligand pd1 pathway by tumor cells can
produce PD ligand or PDL 1 which is kind
of a don't eat me signal where tumor
cells del T sub say don't attack me and
these cells they kind of turn off the
immune system that way and so if you
prevent that pathway from being engaged
with the pd-1 anybody like never lower
half which is a crystal minus quit pd1
anybody or mk-3475 you can actually keep
the T cell from being torn off and
t-cell to kill your tumor cells or you
can prevent this pathway from engaging
and or prevent ctla-4 from completing
with cd28 and turning off signal to and
that way you can get more p cell
activation so you can you can affect the
stats a at multiple levels but
especially if these two that will see be
l84 or pd one and i want to present to
solve the data that we have on the e1
and has been recently presented in both
in the New England Journal and also at
our melanoma meetings and one of these
one of the most exciting has been this
pd-1 antibody that's the Merc pd-1
antibody mk-3475 recently published in
the new NHL and this slide just shows
the one ball plot again showing major
response and showing that all of these
patients here had a tumor shrinkage
which in the context of the earth
inhibitor therapy in brf and mek
inhibitor therapy doesn't sound as a
present but for immune therapy that's
unprecedented that's just that's just an
amazing response rate most of um serapis
you'll see response rates in the other
ten percent twenty percent range seeing
response rates in thirty percent of
fifty percent of the population is
pretty amazing and this just gives this
light gives you an idea of how long live
these responses are and it's what's
known as a slower clock so here of
patients are developing response right
around ten weeks and then you can see
that these blue arrows show show ongoing
responses so you can see that almost
everybody here has ongoing responses and
you can see all of these blue arrows
here these patients have progressed but
everybody else's ongoing response is
showing that even up to a year most
people have ongoing responses and
pointing to the fact that immune therapy
generally produces very long lasting
responses
here's the data for lab realism em or
mk-3475 it's the pd-1 inhibitor and just
showing that at the very highest dose
double that's 10 milligrams per kilogram
given every two weeks patients who were
a balloon man naive head response rates
of a 56% patients who were treated him
also the same and if you looked at the
10 milligram per kilogram every
three-week response rate it's somewhere
between thirty percent to twenty twenty
two percent depending on the weather
patients were naive or treated and at
the lower two milligrams per kilogram
does our responses were in the fourteen
percent range if you look at the ninth
versus it be naughty vs if you treated
you don't see a huge difference kind of
pointing to the fact that response rates
don't really seem to vary depending on
what depending on whether patients have
had it will go mad before or not
initially one of the interesting things
in that trial was that response rate
either by central review or my
investigator assessment don't seem to be
a lot different so showing pretty much
the same response rates in either case
and let's get through the next few
slides here's some of our patients who
be treated and I just just to give you a
flavor of responses so here's a patient
who had lung metastases and you could
see that she's most of these long
velocities of completely respond a
completely request and just shows you
that dissipation who were 12 eggs
apparently showed progression with this
new tumor that showed up in a hilar
lymph node that you could see right here
and then by 24 weeks that that she was
gone and also on her other lung
so gone and here's a patient who had
tumor not just in the lung but also to
mérida born and you can see that by 24
weeks the tumor multiple line and born
was almost discipline and had almost
disappeared it just shows the cat scan
showing a great response and there's a
patient with innumerable innumerable one
lesions you could see multiple in both
lungs and you can see that they are
pretty much gone by the 12 and then
she's had a complete response
subsequently to treatment he is a
patient with with desmoplastic melanoma
of it's the kind of fella know that
that's that's aggressive locally and you
can see that his melon was so advanced
that he could he could not even close
his eyes and you could see here that
means i was totally shut because of the
melanoma affecting his eye and you can
see that after he started treatment he
had some regression tumor ultimately was
able to open his eyes after nine weeks
and has come here to have a nice
response now one other major development
in our field has been a study that was
presented by Jed will jog and his
colleagues and also published in the New
England Journal of Medicine of novella
map which is another pd1 anybody made by
Crystal along with in combination with
ctla-4 and this just shows amazing
response is seen with this combination
and again this is a spy Department
notice how rapid and how sustain these
responses are where patients have two
more that just strings down and then
stage shrunken down and you can look at
from the waterfall plot that a lot of
patients appear to have great responses
and this is a patient with lift or
disease showing nice responses what mole
chalk and colleagues did is that tested
several different doses that try it
nibble omap at a lower dose arm along
with a plume avatar higher dose or other
permutations and combinations and if you
look at their response rate it just
basically shows that the highest
response rate they God was
that never look at one milligram per
kilogram hippie 3 milligrams per
kilogram which was right here fifty
three percent response rate sixty-five
percent clinical activity so quite an
unprecedented number for an
immunotherapy trial if you compare lever
Elizabeth which is the merck anybody
work with nibble of f plus if you love
math which is the bristol antibody you
can see very comparable numbers so in
the combination study you can see that
there was fifty-three percent partial
responses in the highest those level of
the mk-3475 study 56% response rate so
comparable numbers i think one of the
questions that remains to the answer is
is is you know how this will play out in
the next few months or in the next few
years so one other area that has been
upgraded just to me particularly but
also to other people is is using a
cytokine and cytokine therapy to improve
response rates and here and we focus on
research on interleukin-12 which is a
crucial cytokine that's used by
neutrophils and macrophages dendritic
cells to signal to t cells and so this
is a different kind of signaling which
does not involve a t-cell receptor but
but this is a cytokine letting increases
proliferation increases signaling at the
t cell level and so what we've done is
we've actually used gene therapy
approach where if you look at a melanoma
tumor that's right here shown on the
left hand side you can basically inject
your plasmid right into the melanoma
tumor and then using an electrode you
basically insert needles into the tumor
and then within with a short duration
electric pulse go ahead and pulse that
here's my colleague rich Heller who was
who did experiments in in mice initially
and showed that this approach worked
great in in the b16 model and that's me
many years ago and that's the practice
that we used in as in a lab and here's
one of the patients we treated many
years ago this is patient number nine
court three was being written about this
response but basically he had bunch of
lesions on his right chest and also on
his right back so that's those are the
lesions on his right chest and those
other lesions on his right back and
that's that's how it look like
pretreatment we treated poorly and so we
didn't read all of them just just two
three four and then one other leisure
that's not visible it is in this
photograph you can see that about nine
months later a lot of the lesions
flattened out and kind of lost some of
their volume and you would see that even
on his back there was some pavement
changes in some redness run around the
lesions on his back and by year two
lesions have flattened out and all he
would seize some tattoos and and the
lesions on his back also were pretty
much gone by this time you could see
that he also had a separate keratosis
which was not changed by this treatment
and you could see that and we actually
by of seats on these tattoos and
basically found that they were just dead
cells in there so with that I want to
conclude and I think the take-home
messages that this is a time of
unprecedented advances in melanoma
therapy we've seen great advances in
targeted therapy the beer after the
videos with that are now a primary
choice for treatment of V rockets and
spell 11 patients I think one of the
points that I didn't mention what needs
to be emphasized it is that we're are
Filipinos only work for very long
commute a mutated patients and so
testing using an fda certified SI is
essential or clear certified test is
essential so you don't want to treat
b-raf wild-type patients with b-ref
inhibitors we don't think that that's
helpful and may even be diluted to the
curious
the problem of the parameters is that
resistance of the therapy develops
usually between six to eight months
afterwards and you can add MEK
inhibitors to be Ralph inhibitors that
will give you some extra mileage but
still resistance will develop to
treatment also this is a time of great
advance in a neurologic Tara peas and
especially therapies like epilogue map
and this year the pd-1 antibodies have
shown remarkable activity in melanoma
which responses it higher than fifty
percent in greater than fifty percent of
patients and these responses are
long-lived unlike the PM inhibitor
therapies although you cause shrinkage
in a small number of patients you you do
you do certainly have much more
long-lasting responses with immune
therapies I today there wasn't time to
cover this but but antiangiogenic drugs
and chemotherapy drugs also have a role
in some patients although today they're
becoming third or fourth-line therapies
in general with that I'd like to
conclude my talk and then take any
questions if anybody has any thank you
to get in here your could cme credits
please go to www conference live com /
CMA dash c e
so are one of the questions that come in
is our mutations in n r & b RF mutant
mutation mutually exclusive and the
second part of that question is and this
is true will that cause modifications to
treatment so that's a great question and
I didn't talk about that but yes it's
true that they're pretty much mutually
exclusive so that's actually one piece
of data that really made us think that
these are driver mutations and what if
you look at melanomas it's very rare for
beer and mutants felon or must you have
ever asked me mutations also the one
exception to this is when you're
treating me Ralph mutants melanomas with
beer and inhibitors Tony rivers Roger
low and colleagues at UCLA have shown
that secondary entrance mutations can
develop in the European melanoma after
treatment it can be one of the factors
that causes resistance to develop but up
front it's pretty unusual to have beer
at and a transmutation zavala so once
you have a beer app you can tell no one
most people will assume that that cannot
you can also have an ass run over there
so another question from Nagi Lamar Z
and that is was what are the major
toxicities associated with immunotherapy
drugs so that's a great question too so
immunotherapy drugs I think you know as
a general rule have a variety of side
effects and so if you look at
interleukin-2 it if you're on the side
effects from them are usually fevers
chills
sometimes nausea vomiting works on
cytokine release syndrome with a balloon
map the the immune toxicities are very
distinctive and include colitis that can
be responsive to steroids hypothesizes
or reduce secretion of hypothalamic
hormones and also liver function test
abnormalities and dermatitis so serious
adverse events from from these four
system systems are have been maybe about
twenty to thirty percent of patients
with PD 10 the toxicity profile is much
more benign and it's pretty rare to have
serious colitis developed with PD one so
this there's not a lot of cases of
colitis reported with that the one
distinctive toxicity of anyone is
pneumonitis and a few cases of
pneumonitis have been reported and many
of those are patients with lung cancer
or non-small cell lung cancer but but
some cases have been reported in
patients with melanoma as well now
muscle soreness muscle stiffness join
the exchange fatigue but overall the
incidence of serious side effects is
much lower but with the pd-1 George then
it is will it will look ma'am so other
question is that that's come up is is
there any correlation between monocyte
macrophage apoptosis in pd-1 PDL 1 i'm
not sure i'm not sure how much data
there's on this on a tree right I'd have
to be I have to look and see if there is
a correlation between macrophage
apoptosis and p1 PDL one expression I
think people think that stroma
contributes a lot to the PDL one staying
so it's opa1 stating although in the
slide I showed you seems to be localized
on the tumor cells exclusively that's
probably not true that's probably
listing we think there's a lot of strong
expression of ppl one and so the tumor
stroma may contribute some to damping
the immune responsiveness the data that
you know tumors in different places in
the body yeah have a different
expression of ppl one also different
types of tumors you know like now no
more compared to lung cancer or colon
cancer have different expressions of pd
l1 and so I think stroma contributes a
lot to that so another question is is is
from someone who says I'm a 10 year
survivor of GBM I'm also cancer
researcher in addition in 2009 i was
diagnosed with psoriatic arthritis is it
possible that my PSA actually helped me
survive gbn that is with natural high
levels of tnf-alpha yeah I think it's
possible to just think that you know
patients with patients who are on pd-1
therapy can develop arthritis and
myositis and and muscle inflammation and
vitiligo which are all autoimmune
disease in and I know that I've had
patients who can either some type of
arthritis or some type of autoimmune
disease reactivate those once they have
once once that we do it pd-1 so I think
it's possible in your case that that
there might be some linkage between your
psoriatic arthritis n your nice response
to GBM so interesting
I think I think we are still just
uncovering the linkage between the
between the immune system and between
these new therapies I fully expect that
in the next I'd say 10 years people are
going to look at combinations of immune
therapy and targeted therapy also look
to see how we can deepen responses to
some of these immune therapies alright
so that's that's great thank you all for
listening and I want to thank the
organizers for this for this opportunity
and with that I'd like to log off